I'm really concerned about the recent
homicides that we've had of course and
our hearts go out to everybody who's
been affected we have had a bad three
months in terms of homicides and as you
know in the last week just you know five
on my mind in which very young people
have been affected and that's a horrible
horrible thing overall of course people
talk about New York because it used to
be so crime-ridden and it has come down
whether for the rest of this year
London and New York or in similar places
we will see this has been a particularly
bad couple of months for London and a
particularly good couple of months I
mean it's really put you in the
international spotlight I've been
looking at some of the coverage
internationally and okay bit of
hyperbole I'm saw there but they've
they've picked up on that and they've
got the Commissioner now presiding over
a murder rate that's worse than New
York's I mean that that could be your
legacy well I'm hoping to be here for
five years it wouldn't be something they
could have said three months ago and I'm
definitely determined that it won't be
what they'll be able to say in a few
months time I speak to the New York
Commissioner a lot he's been over here
I've been over there there's things we
can learn from each other if you
compared us with say Baltimore or some
other cities ten times 20 times 50 times
the homicide rate I need to learn from
the rest of the world but I need to
concentrate on London and that's what
we're doing we've got three hundred
officers a day extra out over this
weekend we will be using every tactic we
know in the in the coming weeks and
months to bear down on knife crime and
to reduce the number of homicide
interesting what you say about that
extra deployment then is that is that a
sign that you accept this is a crisis
because I was reading some former
offices of course you're serving
officers can't speak but the former
officers clearly in touch with the
serving officers they say it's a crisis
I would not use the word crisis all I
would say is let's focus on the fact
that a number of people have tragically
lost their lives in the last few days
and indeed in the last month and we need
to reduce the number particularly the
number of young people who are dying in
Street attacks
we're often ferocious violence used by
other young people in groups usually not
quite always associated with street drug
dealing this is a very particular
problem which has risen
which has sort of caused the rate of
homicide to rise that's the problem we
need to deal with the police can't do
that alone we need help from government
local government other agencies and most
particularly from the public you'll be
aware of the Glasgow experience with
pretty.i murder rate a decade or so ago
and talking to their violence reduction
units I'm sure you know an awful lot
about talking about that you treat it as
a disease and therefore you involve all
agencies do you feel a bit overexposed
on this that people are regarding it
simply as a policing problem I don't
feel that I or the Mets are overexposed
I do think it is a long-term problem
which requires concerted long-term
effort Glasgow had a ten-year strategy
and as you say they involved everybody
the police have a very important role
and we are doing that we're taking
weapons off the streets we'll be doing
that even more we're stopping and
searching people will be doing that even
more we're targeting the most violent
people we'll be doing that even more and
we will be trying to divert young people
away from crime through our schools
officers our partnership officers and
we're we trying to take our communities
with us have you met any of the victims
families yes I have over the last few
months I've met many many victims
families and I've also met officers who
have tried to save victims lives and
officers of course who have saved
victims lives and I have have met all
kinds of people who have been very badly
affected by a knife crime I see that as
part of my job and this is driving you
on let me talk about some specific
measures and you'd be aware people
talking a lot about stop and search and
you talk about it being a valuable tool
but of course you remember Teresa
Mayer's home secretary asking the police
not to do so much of it but numbers
under you number of stop and searches
have actually fallen there were what
about 70,000 in the last six months of
2016 and 66,000 or so in the last six
months of 2017 weapon searches have
increased weapon seizures have increased
that's what I'm really focusing on I
anticipate they will continue to
increase and while we're on the issue of
statistics what about just the plain
numbers officers on the streets they
have fallen and the mayor Sadiq Khan is
saying they may even drop below 30,000
down at 27,500 in two or three years
time
so I am concerned of course always 24
hours a day how many officers do we have
available on the streets we don't solve
problems like knife crime just through
visible officers on the streets also
through fantastic covert work you'll be
aware of our Trident teams for example
who've been targeting gangsters taking
hundreds of them off the streets
seizing nearly a thousand weapons but
also through our clever analysts and and
through other methods as well so police
officers is a very important thing to
have and visible police officers very
important as well in the fight against
knife crime the mayor has been able to
find us another hundred and twelve
million pounds I'm investing that
entirely in the fight against knife
crime in people and bit in equipment of
course I would always want more people
and I've inherited less than my
predecessor started with that is for
sure but it's also my job to prioritize
and to make sure that we have the right
people in the right places targeting the
most violent people and providing
reassurance and that's what we'll be
doing but just reading into how you put
that obviously very diplomatic about the
numbers but you would always like more
people presumably therefore not fewer as
is the prediction as I say from the
mayor are you at rock bottom now around
about the 30,000 level an awful lot of
things can happen I can't predict what
will happen with our funding it's my job
to make an evidence-based case I did
that in the autumn we have another
hundred and twelve million which we are
now going to be investing in the fight
against knife crime it's my job to look
at what the evidence is and to argue for
more and I will be doing that if I feel
that we cannot get on top of this
problem in commissioner can you make a
prediction that in another years time
you'll be able to to sit in front of the
cameras and and tell us that we are
getting on top of this issue if we take
the example of scooter enabled crime
that had been going up like this in the
two years before I arrived three months
in to my commissioner ship we start in a
whole range of new tactics and we put
even more effort into that and you'll be
aware that's quite a fair amount of that
involves robbery and sometimes in
knives and weapons as well that is now
coming right down I want to see the same
with knife crime I hope we will see the
same with knife crime I do not believe
the police can do that by themselves and
I need others to get involved and I need
the public to help us
and lastly commissioner a question about
not only subject question about
Salisbury because of course the
Metropolitan Police in charge of the
investigation into what happened to the
the screep house what can you tell us
about the state of that investigation
for instance have you even identified
any potential suspects yet so I'm not
gonna give you a an update on the
investigation I will leave that to the
investigation leads and and to Neel Basu
what I will say is it's a very complex
investigation it will obviously be a
very long running investigation it's
great news to hear that's one of the
people who was attacked is in so much
better health and you know our thoughts
are with mr. scruple we will continue
doing our job we will be there for
seeking to establish exactly what's
happened and bringing somebody or some
people to justice if we possibly can and
we will be working with the government
and with the agencies as we do that it's
going to take an awfully long time it
will be a long and complex investigation
yes